okay let's go next to our caller from
the eight five six area code eight five
six go ahead either I am actually a
pretty big fan of your save okay I just
wanted to know how do you distinguish
which hatred mail is authentic and not
because I don't love this looks like you
planted it yeah because there's no way
somebody spilled let's say that many
spelling errors has that many
grammatical errors and it's that extreme
well on that you're wrong see my inbox
in fact the the actual the the spelling
and grammar of hatred mail is not that
rare in terms of the broader email that
I receive its the vitriol that is what
gets singled out for hatred mail now a
big deal has been made out of like
what's David Pakman got to take my Alex
Jones what's David Pakman a strategy for
distinguishing real and fake hatred mail
it's not that it's like a big secret but
I'm not gonna tell you everything we do
because then people are gonna go out of
their way to try to get fake hatred
email now I want to actually say
something else doesn't matter one way or
the other like it's an entertainment
segment that relates to extremist
ideology so even if like they were
completely made-up which they're not I
don't know that it actually changes the
segment that much because no one would
ever really know but speaking
heart-to-heart with you here we have a
pretty good sense like there there are
there are five or six markers that we
look for we can also check our email
history with the person there's other
things we can look at and their presence
in our ecosystem but you know I can't
give it all away here because then
people would just become obsessed fake
hate Reba okay yeah all right keep them
coming all right thank you appreciate it
we'll do it but listen we will because
in the Trump era there is a deluge of
hatred we don't need to fake it like it
would be a different I wish we needed to
fake it but we don't I was gonna say
your hatred mail process is a lot like
the Trump foreign policy in that one
it's extreme vetting yeah and two you
don't want to really share what the
process is because I don't want to give
it away then the enemy will know that's
right let's take a quick break if you're
on hold
don't hang up because we're gonna take
more phone
calls shortly